[Music]
you can just be someone different you
can defend whatever you want it's time
to get creepy with the Kardashians the
famous family goes all-out for every
holiday and Halloween is no exception
Wonder Woman I did it why not back in
the day Kim was the queen of sexy
Halloween I'm freaking out scary but
then the sisters grew up a bit and took
more of a spirited spooky approach
instead yes that's Kim and Kanye as
Batman and Catwoman Jonathan Cheban as
the Riddler and Kourtney and Scott as
Batgirl and Robin Chloe and her beau
Tristan Thompson went the same route as
they channeled superheroes storm and
black panther
and then the Disick's went full avenger
as the whole squad guys I'm bringing the
party to you but the sexy is not all
gone little sis kylie is keeping things
hot on the holiday the 20 year old has
shown off plenty of skin on Halloween
especially in 2016 when she paid tribute
to Christina Aguilera sexy scary who
knows what they'll do this year which
kardashian costume are you most excited
for tweet me at Deidre Behar oh that's
wild
[Music]